there's strange comfort in solitude half
and wonder how did it come to this
was it her I'm Russ oh I know who you
are you're Russ Washington Russ
yes mr. Lowenstein no I get it sir it's
not could be an issue so that was the
studio a taking where are we crying
schedule on the first day of shooting
most Nicki Russians suck you were 400
grand I'm not bailing you out again
that's 1.3 million you owe me I give you
a week to come up with the rest I'm
starting to think you got a problem
Bailey but look this top hope is gracing
us with their presence the 50 million
dollar man check this what up how do you
know her well fun banging the same
hookers at 50 million dollar man it must
be doing it right you didn't know can't
you talk to me like an adult and tell me
what's wrong I'm not least the biggest
sell my career my best friend slash
business partner is a degenerate gambler
owned the best part of the one you're
really gonna like is the girl I'm in
love with its profitable keen again feel
like I don't even know you
so it's gonna cost to fix this what did
I tell you Ross said if I couldn't get
things under control you find Sona could
and can't stop thinking how did it come
to this if I'm gonna be honest it was me
[Music]
you